So far, we've seen two aggregation operators, group and sort. There
are several others in addition to these two. I'm going to
go through each one briefly to explain how it works. I'll
just summarize them here. Later we'll dig into each one individually, and
I'll show you what it does. All right, so the first
operator we'll look at is project. I've put together some dummy
data here that we can use as we talk about each
one of these operators. Now, the project operator, allows you to shape
documents you receive as input into what you need for
the next stage. The simplest form of shaping is using
project to select which fields you're interested in exactly. Like
we did in the last lesson, when projecting out the
motto for cities, and other single fields we were interested
in looking at. So for example here, if in the
documents I receive to my stage in which I'm using
the project operator, I'm interested, say, in this field, and perhaps
this one as well. Then I can use the
Project operator to simply pull out these individual values, regardless
of where they're nested in the input documents. And,
project them out in documents, into the next stage of
the pipeline, or the result if I'm at the
end of the pipeline. We'll look at the syntax for
Project a little bit later. Essentially with Project I can
take the fields I receive in an individual document, and
perform a number of different types of operations on
them, in order to produce documents for the next stage
of the pipeline. Select is one. I could also
say, for example, as we'll look at later, produce a
ratio based on two numeric fields and create a
new field that will then be passed on in documents
to the next stage of the pipeline. The next
operator I want to look at is match. Match filters documents,
so for example, I might set up some match criteria
that might cause me to end up filtering, so that
I only ended up with this document and this document.
>From the documents I was passed as input to my aggregation
stage using the new match operator. I can, of course,
also group and sort. And we looked at a pretty detailed
example for both of these, so I wont' go into
further detail here. So the next operator I'd like to cover
is skip. Skip is designed to allow us to simply
skip over a certain number of documents at the beginning
of our input set of documents to the aggregation stage
using skip. So, for example, if I wanted to skip
the first three input documents. Then the first document I
would output would be this one, and all documents following
it. Limit kind of does the reverse of skip, so
in this case, if I limited what I was passing on
to the next stage of the pipeline to three documents. Then what I
would be doing, is simply taking those
three documents and filtering out everything else.